the three Muslims upon brother Andrew
Tate coming to Islam alhamdulillah I've
seen a lot of sisters have a very
emotional reaction of he doesn't deserve
Islam what so what he's just forgiven
for what he did and all this emotional
stuff
foreign
foreign
listen
left his house to kill the prophet he
left his house to kill the prophet some
things happened when he got to where the
Prophet saws was he accepted Islam
did the prophet say you had the
intention of coming and killing me you
know
um be gone no look at Allah
he went to war against the prophet he
killed companions he lets the death of
Companions of the Apostles he led to the
process of getting injured Gravely
and he came and he said you know ask
Allah he accepted Sam he said ask Allah
to forgive me and the prophet said he
said don't you know that Islam forgives
all sins basically when you accept Islam
you're forgiven
so if he's sincerely generally accepted
Islam he is Forgiven it's not for you or
me to come and say he doesn't deserve it
because your pleasure is not greater
than the pleasure of Allah are you not
liking it it does not matter if Allah is
pleased and the same thing with me if
someone I really disliked accepted Islam
well guess what they're my brother or
sister now I have to accept it and
whether we like it or not that's what
Islam calls for and if you are truly a
Muslim if you're truly a Muslim you will
love what Allah loves and you will hate
what Allah hates and you can dislike the
actions and the things he said in the
past but you must love the fact that we
have a new brother in Islam
and and you gotta think anyone who says
something like this sister or brother
like who are you to say something like
this
you know like oh he doesn't deserve
Islam well have you asked yourself that
question
do you deserve Islam because I asked
myself that question every day and I get
to the conclusion that I don't even
deserve Islam I don't deserve guidance
but here Allah is blessing me with
guidance so if you're trying to say that
oh this person doesn't deserve Islam
because of what they did this like
stop pointing the finger quit projecting
like look at yourself in the mirror ask
yourself and humble yourself because
again like Allah
said that um
anyone who has just an
ounce this this this little bit of
arrogance
won't be in general
I think it was the idea of the personal
Center yeah
yeah and now you got women bro you got
Muslim sisters that are literally
tweeting and I'll read this up bro just
so you guys because I I initially
thought these were jokes bro but one
literally says but if Andrew has
actually become a Muslim or parades
himself around us Muslims and gets
accepted right meaning like bro who are
you to see if he's going to be accepted
or not and it says I'm leaving Islam
wallahi all abandon Islam in this Dunya
all together
Muslims are honestly the most mentally
ill subservient idiots on Earth
and when Allah asks why I'll tell him
this is this was a sister
a lot of sisters are heated bro a lot of
sisters are legitimately they're Pro and
a lot of them I thought they were fake
right they're Muslim women in hijabis
they got a verified check mark bro
they're looking real they're real people
influencers bro that have a following
they have an audience they have reach
they have influence and they're going
around saying oh just because Andrew
take him I'm leaving bro yeah I see this
thing I see this in islamophobic uh
propaganda bro or super like Orthodox
Christian right of course like they're
gonna make it pain out to be like that
but when I'm seeing Muslim sisters bro
doing this come on yeah yeah and let me
let me be fair the sisters because I was
very direct in the beginning
alhamdulillah rightfully so but let me
be fair that is sisters a lot of them
have a fear that since he has a lot of
say over common people
if he were to come into Islam and
continue with certain narratives that he
had before Islam and try and Associate
those narratives with Islam he will
misguide the Muslims even more even more
and even even worse than he did before
and I think that's a valid concern I
don't think and and that doesn't mean
every valid concern needs to be voiced
you don't need to voice it
I think maybe mention there's a
possibility and we should be careful but
to jump to this extreme is too much and
I also want to mention that Yani these
are sisters you know these are sisters
they're naturally just more emotionally
volatile
than men and I'm not saying they are
forgiven but there have been instances
got jealous and she like slapped the
Train on the table didn't yell at her
like go be harsh with her or anything so
maybe I was too harsh in the beginning
maybe not Aloha out of my point stands
regardless at the end of the day
what would you like more
that he stays a non-muslim and continues
persisting in whatever he was he was on
before or that he comes to Islam and
fully accepts it and renounces the
things that he said in the past
because of Allah for the sake of Allah
which would be better in your eyes
yeah I don't think you were too harsh to
be honest because if a woman says I mean
look look let's put it aside let's put
let's put the agendas aside here right
whether it's a woman or a man like if
someone says like oh
um if if so-and-so continues and like
he's accepted by Muslims and other stuff
then I'm Gonna Leave Islam like
I'm sorry it's you can you can be
emotional right you can be illogical you
can say things out of emotion out of
anger and be Petty sometimes but like to
say something like that
you should not be you should not be
saying stuff like that I'm gonna play
around I see another three bro I'm not
gonna say the name or I'm gonna blur the
picture too but she says Andrew Tate
promotes adult videos uh breaking
families
as trafficking Etc and Muslim Brothers
say may Allah guide him
Muslim girl wears jeans and our brothers
say dirty
bro
like what brother has said Mela guide
him because of the things he's doing
because we support these things we say
these things because he's so misguided
before Islam that we want him to be
guided and now that he's actually
accepted Islam we want to be here for
him to change his ways
and you're including that with a woman
who is a Muslim and wearing jeans like I
don't know bro I think what she's trying
to say is when we see Andrew Tate and
I'm not saying he does or doesn't do
these things but she's naming horrendous
crimes she's like when Andrew Kate does
horrendous crimes the brothers are like
oh may Allah guide him and when a sister
does something small the brothers like
lose their mind at her I see what she's
saying I think it has some weight there
are brothers like that again it's a huge
generalization and may Allah guide
everyone male and female men and women
um but again it's Yanni like at the end
of the day this brother has accepted
Islam whether anyone likes it or not he
has accepted Islam we have in Amana we
have a duty we have a responsibility a
trust given to us by Allah
and this is a very crucial time it's a
very crucial time we can be arrogant we
can be Petty we can be immature and we
can push someone away from Islam and
also yield the sins of that or we can be
mature we could be good Muslims we could
be brothers and sisters and we could be
good Believers in Allah we can encourage
good and forbid evil and perhaps one day
insha Allah when he's deeper in Islam he
has a good solid connection with Allah
he's very close with his Deen he looks
at the life the prophet salaam he
realizes some of the things he said and
did in the past were I guess Islam and
he renounces them what if he studies
Islam and he starts teaching which is
good and he starts standing up for
Islamic Islamic women's rights is that
not what you would want so let's take
this time and invest in the brother
insha Allah
and just remember like
he just reverted
he he just revered
give this man time
I give this man time just make the wife
man instead of being upset instead of
trying to claim this this and that and
making assumptions and saying oh this is
what's going to happen over here and
over there
just make do uh
if if she wanted the best just make the
world
that's it Daniel hook he got you posted
this uh this Meme and basically it was
just him praying like Andrew tape prank
and then you got a bunch of like it's
like the salafi you know and like a like
a cartoon and he's just like you know
making the offer mail like item Mela
bless him and then there's like this
like this uh I think it was like some
rainbow wearing like you know Muslim
liberal whatever saying why are you guys
making Dua for him and I'm like bro
that's so telling because at the end of
the day they're acting like tawba isn't
a thing repentance isn't a thing being
forgiven for your past after accepting
Islam isn't a thing as a human being
brought as a fallible human being we're
making these claims bro after knowing
Allah talks about the munafic the
Hypocrites in the Quran so much bro
come on yeah yeah worse people have
accepted Islam bro look at the Mongols
go go watch a five minute video about
what the Mongols did to the Muslims and
know that they this community these
people became Muslim later on
and then you'll you'll you'll really you
know you'll really be quiet about you
know Andrew take coming to Islam
I'm downstairs the prophetam he may die
foreign
who was a staunch enemy and caused a lot
of pain for the Muslims in the beginning
he may go out for him to bring him to
Islam
hmm
with that being said